pourquoi
bruxelles et moscou les deux blocs font
le point au lendemain de mal pas de
remise en cause des alliances gage de
stabilité en europe
après le succès du front national à
dreux jean-marie le pen demande
l'annulation de la législative de
marseille
motif l'intervention télévisée du
premier ministre
nouvelle épreuve de force en
tchécoslovaquie trois cent mille
manifestants dénoncent le gouvernement
reprise des négociations avec
l'opposition
attention à la grille elle fera preuve
de plein fouet dans quinze jours il est
important de vous faire vacciner
madame monsieur bonsoir on vit vraiment
une époque formidable et on s'habitue
vite aux situations et aux phrases les
plus stupéfiantes depuis 40 ans en gros
on connaissait l'opposition irréductible
des deux blocs le temps d'un côté le
pacte de varsovie de l'autre et la
ritournelle des arguments justifiant le
renforcement réciproque
plus récemment des temps oblige l'union
soviétique réclamé à chaque occasion la
dissolution des alliances militaires et
bien depuis malte tout elle changé voilà
qu'à bruxelles aujourd'hui les
dirigeants de l'alliance atlantique se
préoccupe de la survie du pacte de
varsovie dans une robe bouleversé le
maintien des alliances militaires des
deux côtés devient à gages de stabilité
à bruxelles laurent boussier jatte à
bouchehr l'évolution politique en europe
de l'est diminution des menaces
militaires des armements rencontre de
malte en quelques heures tous ces sujets
ont été abordés par les chefs d'état ou
de gouvernement qui pour la deuxième
fois cette année participer à un sommet
de l'otan un sommet où george bush a
rendu compte à ses alliés de ses
discussions avec michael gorbatchev un
sommet où américains et européens
étaient pour la première fois en phase
sur l'attitude à avoir face aux
bouleversements de l'aide
une concordance qui n'était pas évidente
tant reste grand le décalage militaire
entre les deux europe 55 division du
pacte de varsovie font toujours face à
24 division de l'otan mais les choses
évoluent en tous ont décidé d'accorder
leur confiance à michael gorbatchev et
surtout de ne rien tenter qui puisse le
déstabiliser à l'intérieur de son propre
pays
pour s'adapter au désarmement l'otan
devra lui passer d'une structure
essentiellement militaire à une
structure apte à traiter les problèmes
politiques diplomatiques voire
économique
mais là encore george bush a tenu à
rassurer ses alliés les états unis
maintiendront une présence militaire
significative en europe tant que leurs
alliés le voudront c'est évidemment la
phrase clé que souhaitait entendre les
alliés des etats unis
même satisfaction en ce qui concerne
malte je n'ai pas eu de gênes pour
l'europe a déclaré françois mitterrand
une façon élégante pour dire n'accusons
pas les deux grands de manoeuvre et de
manigances
le président de la république a
d'ailleurs donné le ton il employait
deux mots espoir et intérêts pour
appuyer les idées de george bush qu'il
s'agisse d'un accord sur les armes
conventionnelles chimiques ou
stratégiques c'est à dire les grosses
fusée monsieur mitterrand a une autre
raison de se réjouir alors qu'il est
convaincu de longue date par l'action de
gorbatchev
avant de rencontrer à kiev le leader
soviétique
il constate que george bush à son tour
entend soutenir à fond l'inventeur de la
pérestroïka justement en même temps ou
presque à moscou mikhaïl gorbatchev
réunissent et ses alliés en tout cas ce
que lis encore malgré les
bouleversements laissant le pacte de
varsovie la réunion ressemblait à tout
sauf à un portrait de famille et il
n'est pas sûr que les intérêts des uns
et des autres soit encore les mêmes
georges bortoli egon krenz était là avec
le premier ministre mme gaudreault bien
que monsieur crès le soin à fait plus
grand chose depuis la dernière grande
purge du bureau politique est allemand
le général younès qui lui est apparu
presque tout seul son premier ministre
non communiste restant loin derrière
monsieur church et school le
traditionnaliste purs et durs voisiner
avec les hongrois qui au contraire ce
coup allègrement les dogme marxiste
léniniste bref c'était une assemblée
vraiment bien mélanger que c'est réussi
du pacte de varsovie et on peut même se
demander si ce pacte de varsovie qui
était fondée sur la cohésion étroite
autour de moscou des six pays qu'on
qualifie a pas si longtemps de cette
élite si ce pacte de varsovie existe
toujours alors que les satellites sont
de moins en moins satellite et c'est la
tchécoslovaquie aujourd'hui qui était
très en compte puisque premièrement elle
a demandé que soit posée la question du
retrait des troupes soviétiques du
territoire tchécoslovaque et que
deuxièmement alors ça c'est encore plus
fort je crois moscou a reconnu très
solennellement que l'invasion de la
tchécoslovaquie en 68 par l'urss bien
sûr et par quatre autres pays membres du
pacte de varsovie dont la république
démocratique allemande que cette
invasion constituer une erreur qu'elle
était condamnable que c'était je cite
une ingérence dans les affaires
intérieures
en somme c'est le grand frère chiliens
ont presque en tout cas demandant pardon
aux petits frères ça s'est tout de même
je crois très très très nouveau alors la
nouvelle carte de l'europe qui préoccupe
donc bruxelles comme moscou aujourd'hui
on la retrouve en filigrane dans la
préparation du prochain sommet des 12 à
strasbourg à la fin de la semaine
le président mitterrand rentrer à paris
en fin d'après midi a commencé selon la
tradition élyséenne a consulté à ce
sujet les chefs des principales
formations politiques il a donc reçu
kermoroc'h pour le parti socialiste et
pour lille et valéry giscard d'estaing
l'ancien président a demandé pour sa
part une accélération de l'union de
leurs les milieux politiques français ça
juste tant bien que mal au coude sort du
week end avec l'élection en force à
dreux de la candidate du front national
qui retrouve ainsi un siège à
l'assemblée nationale jean marie le pen
en veut non pas un mais deux pour
rattraper le siège de marseille et gagné
hier de justesse par l'udf jean marie le
pen va déposer un recours en annulation
la justification selon lui les propos
tenus par le premier ministre à 7 sur 7
avant la clôture du scrutin à marseille
henri pascal pays ou à le front national
c'est l'intégrisme en politique
c'est vraiment l'incitation à la haine
et à la violence
je veux répéter ce mot parce que c'est
comme ça que je le ressens je crois que
c'est vrai c'est un intégrisme et tout
intégrisme et toujours fanatiques
le premier ministre a délibérément
procéder à une agression politique
contre le front national
alors que l'un de ses candidats l'une de
ses candidates en l'occurrence était à
marseille en pleine opération de vote
notre si le premier ministre n'a pas
cité nommément la ville de marseille il
est vrai qu'en revanche il n'a pas
hésité à parler du fond national en des
termes bien précis le fait est
qu'aujourd'hui jean marie le pen profite
de l'occasion
la loi est claire tant que le scrutin
n'est pas clos toute qualification d'un
adversaire est interdite mais il est à
noter qu'hier soir à marseille entre 19
et 20 heures il n'y eut que 250 votants
or l'écart final entre le candidat udf
est la candidate du front national et
2004 104 voix que le premier ministre
ait parlé ou non du front national
n'aurait donc guère changer les choses
semble t-il les chiffres sont là pour le
prouver à matignon ne semble d'ailleurs
pas s'en émouvoir outre mesure pour
restent néanmoins prudents ou juge du
temps d'apprécier réactions et
commentaires aux résultats d'hier
continuent de pleuvoir trahissons
l'embarras de la classe politique
voici quelques phrases en vrac le parti
communiste en plus que jamais la main
aux démocrates pour combattre l'extrême
droite raciste et fasciste dit andré
lajoinie pierre mauroy lui s'en prend à
jacques chirac qui n'agit pas en homme
d'état responsable dit in puisque le rpr
tente par démagogie dans le piège tendu
par le front national
fin de citation jacques chirac lui
accuse françois mitterrand et les
socialistes d'avoir joué aux apprentis
sorciers leur oublions les invectives et
re retenons les faits c'est à dire les
chiffres ces chiffres prouvent les
glissements des électeurs traditionnels
qui ont eu lieu hier à dreux jean-michel
mercurol la force d'attraction du front
national selon l'ifop c'est exercer bien
avant le second tour puisque 58% des
lecteurs rpr ainsi que 20% d'électeurs
socialistes des législatives de 88
on voter cette fois marie france
stirbois dès le premier tour un
transfert de voix a confirmé par le
sondage bva qui donne 61 % des lecteurs
de jacques chirac et 38 % des lecteurs
de françois mitterrand qui ont voté hier
à l'extrême droite
globalement 41% des électeurs de marie
france stirbois n'avait jamais jusqu'ici
voter front national la hausse de
participation au second tour a plus
profité au front national qu'au front
anti le pen puisque de nombreux
électeurs de gauche ou bien se sont
abstenus ou bien ont voté blanc ou nul
la dynamique anti front national a mal
fonctionné
elle a même pu avoir un effet repoussoir
puisqu'il y à entre 10 et 14 %
d'électeurs rpr du premier tour qui ont
voté front national au 2ème une
conséquence possible du soutien de
gauche ou candidat de droite
parmi les motivations des nouveaux
électeurs front national figure en tête
l'immigration le tchador la sécurité
al'inverse c'est la lutte contre le
racisme qui vient en tête des
préoccupations des électeurs du candidat
rpr
à commencer par ceux des électeurs de
gauche qui ont voté pour lui il faut
penser que le tabou qui jusqu'à présent
retenait d'électeurs de gauche de voter
pour un collier à une droite extrême il
a cédé je pense que les circonstances
ils sont pour une large part c'est en
partie d'affaires de creil d'ailleurs la
plupart des électeurs le dise
est ce que cette victoire du front
national est un phénomène de
circonstances liées à des partielles ou
bien ce cas votre avis c'est un
phénomène de fond les deux à mon sens
deux circonstances où il est plus facile
dans une action partiel qui n'a pas
d'enjeux immédiats de se défouler il ya
probablement c'est un coup de semonce
qu'on adresse à la classe politique cela
dit les élections partielles ont souvent
une valeur de signes avant-coureurs et
annonciateurs et ce qui a de nouveau en
la circonstance c'est qu'il est possible
un candidat extrême de l'emporter dans
une partielle à un scrutin majoritaire
et savent à l'encontre de l'idée reçue
jusqu'à présent qu il n'y a vait
d'avenir pour le front national que dans
un scrutin proportionnel
la france est ternie ce n'est plus de la
politique c'est le début de la saison de
la grippe
nous sommes en zone de pré-alerte disent
les spécialistes
en clair ça veut dire que la grippe
commence
wihr mais ce sera pire dans quinze jours
dr la brousse hier dimanche 800 appels
de plus que d'habitude pour ce service
d'urgence parisien les médecins voient
leurs premiers cas de grippe mais
l'épidémie semble déjà prendre de
l'ampleur impression confirmée par le
centre de surveillance de la grippe de
l'inserm qui recueille des informations
en provenance de 500 médecins
sentinelles le virus de la grippe est
donc bien arrivé il s'agit du type
shanghai celui là même que les experts
attendaient ici à l'institut pasteur
on se déclare en zone de pré alerte pour
l'instant nous isolons de nombreux virus
en particulier la région parisienne le
virus circule donc dans la population
ça signifie que dans une dizaine ou une
quinzaine de jours nous serons
probablement en pleine épidémie alors ça
signifie aussi qu'il est temps de se
faire vacciner mais qu'il est grand
temps
la semaine prochaine il sera sans doute
trop tard et les grands malades pour qu
on le sait le virus peut être dangereux
la vaccination s'impose donc mais pour
qu'elles puissent être encore efficace
il faut absolument la faire en ce début
de semaine
vous avez bien entendu attention surtout
pour les personnes âgées et les gens à
santé fragile tant qu'il ya la menace de
grippe ou la grippe et en plus sa
pollution
les nyonnais ont du mal à respirer
depuis quelques jours l'alerté à la
pollution atmosphérique a été déclenchée
ce matin se fit jaune en matière de
pollution les lyonnais sont donc aux
premières loges
ces footballeurs suivent au radar le
ballon fantôme
depuis ce matin la ville est dans le
rouge
les niveaux de dioxyde de soufre émis
par les industries chauffage et
automobile atteignent 300 milligrammes
par mètre cube d'air
soit trois fois plus que le seuil
d'alert principal responsable de cette
situation l'anticyclone mais surtout l'
inversion de température c'est à dire
des températures en altitude supérieure
à celle au sol un véritable couvercle
qui empêche l'évacuation des polluants
usines et chaufferie urbaine ont été
invités à réduire leur consommation
l'alertent pourrait durer plusieurs
jours
à paris la situation n'est pas plus
réjouissante
cet appareil qui mesure à partir de la
lumière la pollution dans un rayon d'un
kilomètre et demi autour de la tour
saint jacques a enregistré depuis
dimanche une importante dégradation de
la qualité de l'air
une pollution automobile là aussi
fortement aggravée par les conditions
météo
la crise reste ouverte en
tchécoslovaquie pour la première fois
depuis huit jours
trois cent mille personnes ont manifesté
tout à l'heure à prague pour protester
contre la forte emprise du parti
communiste sur le gouvernement le
nouveau gouvernement et aussi pour
exiger la démission du président usac
jean-marc il use comme voilà deux
semaines des centaines de milliers de
prague wa de nouveau dans la rue pour
clamer aujourd'hui bien haut leur
indignation après les changements de
façade
opéré dimanche à la tête du gouvernement
adam est alors même que le rôle
dirigeant du parti vient d'être abolie
dans la constitution
seize des 21 membres du nouveau bureau
politique sont membres du parti
communiste donc encore et toujours les
titulaires des ministères de l'intérieur
et de la défense poste pour lesquelles
l'opposition exigé la désignation d'un
non communiste et d'un civil et malgré
l'absence de monsieur adam est reparti à
moscou écoutez le compte rendu de
monsieur gorbatchev après la con
de malte des négociations se sont
engagées entre le vice premier ministre
et forum civique
le mouvement qui parle au nom de
l'opposition et menacent d'ailleurs
d'une nouvelle grève générale
cette nuit pour la première fois depuis
l'avènement du régime communiste en 48
les tchécoslovaques ont pu librement
franchir la frontière avec l'autriche
mais ils ne se sont pas précipités les
devises étrangères sont bien trop cher
en allemagne de l'est le principal
mouvement d'opposition le nouveau forum
demande un référendum sur la
réunification des deux allemagnes tout à
l'heure à leipzig près de deux cent
mille personnes ont manifesté pour la
réunification contre la corruption du
parti communiste et aussi pour exiger
l'organisation d'élections libres en
allemagne de l'est
les manifestants paraissait plus nerveux
que d'habitude comme si la déroute du
parti communiste creuser de plus en plus
le vide du pouvoir
une commission d' enquête conjointe
gouvernement opposition a été mise en
place ce matin pour explorer l'étendue
des abus de pouvoir et de la corruption
et selon certaines rumeurs les dossiers
les plus compromettants serait parti
pour la roumanie cette sensation de
désarroi jérôme monier roger moore ont
constaté à rostock sur la baltique au
sein même du milieu contestataires
rostock sur la baltique est l'une de ces
villes est allemande à l'atmosphère
particulièrement pesant d'abord parce
qu'elle est pollué cette atmosphère les
chiffres restent secrets mais on sait
que les normes internationales ne sont
pas appliquées et puis rostock reste
l'un des bastions du parti communiste
est-allemand
tout est étroitement contrôlé la stasi
la police secrète est omniprésent
dans son collimateur notamment ce groupe
de squatteurs qui se bat depuis
plusieurs années pour l'environnement et
les libertés
lui qu'à y fut emprisonné deux mois en
85 pour avoir milité dans l'armée contre
les missiles soviétiques ss20 implanté
en rd 1 depuis il n'a pas baissé la
garde
pas plus que son épouse dina ou leurs
amis cornelia la difficulté n'était pas
réservé à l'opposition
si t'es dur ou tous ceux qui ne
s'engageait pas dans les mouvements
officielle comme par exemple les
jeunesses communistes
moi mes activités je n'ai pas eu de
problème je savait jusqu'où je pouvais
aller depuis un mois leur marge de
manoeuvre s'est largement ouverte
dina peut être aujourd'hui affichée sur
le landau de sa dernière fille leur
appartenance aux nouveaux forums
ils peuvent distribuer des tracts à des
passants encore étonné incrédule du jour
au lendemain ils ont découvert à quel
point la population était avec eux
personnellement je ne m'attendais pas à
un tel succès je me réjouis beaucoup
cela prouve que nous sommes un mouvement
de masse un mouvement civique du peuple
iranien
parti seul car il est aujourd'hui porté
par un mouvement qui remplit les églises
protestantes de tous les courants de
l'opposition
les orateurs condamne à la fois la
corruption les apparatchiks encore en
place et la société de consommation
capitaliste qui frappent à la porte
mais tout cela sans animosité il s'agit
avant tout de calmer le jeu dans la rue
la manifestation qui suit est massive
mais pacifique
même devant l'immeuble de la stasi à
laquelle chacun dans le cortège a au
moins une bonne raison d'en vouloir la
foule réussi à s'autodiscipliner et
manifestent pacifiquement son hostilité
en allemagne fédérale les industriels ne
perdent pas de temps pour réaliser à
leur manière une forme de réunification
économique
ainsi on apprend aujourd'hui que
volkswagen veut créer une société mixte
en allemagne de l'est et que le groupe
de presse springer veut prendre des
participations dans plusieurs
publications est-allemand la crise
économique mine l'europe de l'est la
monnaie polonaise d'évaluer nouvelle
fois aujourd'hui et aussi le florin ont
droit d'évaluer de 10% en gris les
produits alimentaires augmentent il faut
investir vos capitaux en gris c'est le
message que martèlent à paris depuis ce
matin le hongrois imre pozsgay où le
chef de file des réformateurs
il sera tout à l'heure juste après le
journal l'invité de l'heure de vérité il
est déjà en place vous voyez monsieur
paul dhaille acides dans le décor du
studio alors qu'ils aient imre paul
caille son portrait jacques berrebi la
réforme en gris est conduite par trois
âmes miklos nemeth 41 ans premier
ministre c'est lui qui gère la
transition du pouvoir
en attendant le résultat des élections
en mars prochain prisonnière 54 ha est
le patron du nouveau parti socialiste
elle a joué un rôle important dans
l'abandon du marxisme léninisme imre
pozsgay 56 ans ministre d'état il serait
sans doute déjà président de la
république hongroise
si l'opposition ne l'avait fait chuter
par un référendum
imre page gaye est un intellectuel et un
homme d'appareil diplômé d'histoire et
de philosophie il fut directeur de
l'institut du marxisme léninisme
rédacteur en chef de l'organe du parti
ministre la culture membre du comité
central et du bureau politique de
l'ancien parti communiste il a vécu dans
les entrailles du monstre et en connaît
tous les détours il offre l'image d'un
homme rusé
sous des dehors de bonhomie placide à
l'extrême il guettait surveille comme un
chat pouvant sortir ses griffes ou
ronronner selon l'évolution des
circonstances
aujourd'hui son destin semble moins sûr
le prochain président de la république
hongroise sera élu après les élections
législatives
et nul ne sait comment s'établira alors
le rapport des forces politiques en gris
rendez vous donc à l'heure de vérité
juste après le journal l'opinion
française continue de se mobiliser pour
les chrétiens libanais une centaine de
parlementaires et d'intellectuels de
tous bords de jean d'ormesson à jean
lacouture appel d' à manifester demain
soir à paris le général yen ou la case
se prépare lui a conseillé à beyrouth le
général aoun sur place le travail a
repris aujourd'hui dans le pays chrétien
après une semaine de grève
le reportage de pierre servent du côté
des irréductibles pas d'évolution
significative évident soutenu par des
milliers de chrétiens ayant à ses côtés
une partie de l'armée libanaise le
général aoun chef toujours beyrouth est
les palais de la république à baabda
on se prépare au combat s'il est
idyllique terre sur le terrain les
forces syriennes resserrent leur étau
autour de beyrouth est de la zone
chrétienne les chiffres des voiliers
engagés de weert apprécié en fait était
le plus
au moins 300 chambres d'hôtes en pièces
d'artillerie et d'une dizaine de
milliers d'hommes
on peut voir ces développements tactique
qu'il était interdit de filmer en allant
rencontrer le nouveau président agacera
oui il s'est établi en attendant qu'une
solution se dégage dans la vallée de la
bekaa de sa vie deux harley gardé par
l'autre partie de l'armée libanaise dans
la caserne d'aplats à 70 km de beyrouth
on a besoin jusqu'à nouvel homme de défi
diète
moi je prends mes responsabilités et
temps le président de la république avec
mon gouvernement que le retrait commence
immédiatement
dans la région on n'a pas besoin des
cendres dans d'autres régions comme
beyrouth ouest par le derby à la
montagne
je ne peux pas dire maintenant que je
demanderai aux syriens qui ne veut pas
faire une action mise mais le jour je
serai obligé après elle c'est elle en
ajoutant mais peut-être d'une semaine
peut-être maximum 10 jours
je ne peux pas laisser le pays dans
l'état où elle est le prix nobel de la
paix 89,7 à paris le dalaï lama a reçu
aujourd'hui en même temps que l'avocat
serge klarsfeld et le directeur du musée
de la mémoire arménienne
le premier prix de la mémoire le chef
spirituel et temporel des tibétains
s'était entretenu auparavant avec un
représentant des dissidents chinois
il a parlé de l'état du monde à patricia
kaas est un franc brisset fille alors
que la répression chinoise au tibet de
plus en plus dur je considère que ce
prix est une grève indication de la
reconnaissance internationale de valeurs
telles que la compassion ou la non
violence
bien sûr et naturellement comme je
reçois de plus en plus le soutien
j'ai de plus en plus de courage pour
dire aux autres que la non violence est
quelque chose de très important et de
très utiles et que la compassion et
l'amour sont les sources mêmes du
bonheur du succès les clés de la
puissance voilà aujourd'hui ce que
vous dire avec plus de force encore
peut-être confusion aux philippines les
militaires rebelles semble toujours
tenir un quartier de la capitale mining
and consignes interdiction d'entrée zone
de guerre derrière ces panneaux au moins
dix morts aujourd'hui à manille dont un
japonais et un américain et centaines
d'étrangers sont toujours bloqués dans
le quartier des affaires où s'affrontent
troupes loyalistes et rebelles selon le
porte-parole des mutins
ces étrangers pourraient être évacuées
demain
les loyers pour renault billancourt
selon henri krasucki la fermeture du
site serait un non sens
au moment où la fin de la guerre froide
ouvre de nouvelles perspectives des
changes
cette déclaration intervient au premier
jour du comité central d'entreprise de
renault 6 tonnes de cannabis saisies en
région parisienne une vingtaine
d'interpellations dont trois
inculpations à marseille
l'office de répression du trafic de
stupéfiants présente aujourd'hui sa plus
grosse prise de cannabis depuis 84 du
cannabis libanais
deuxième manche en faveur de robert
hersant dans le procès qui l'oppose au
tandem seydoux berlusconi le tribunal de
commerce de paris confirme ce soir
robert hersant comme patron de la cinq
toutefois le csa devrait statuer
prochainement sur la gestion de la
chaîne
à la bourse de paris en hausse de 1,01
pour cent de l' indice des compagnies
d'agent de change calculée sur 40
valeurs le cac 40 se dollar s'échange en
très légère hausse à 6 francs 08 90 au
cours officiel
on parlait encore une fois sur sa
défaite la nuit dernière à new york et
en avec thor stefan edberg le suédois
avait pourtant perdu cinq fois de suite
les dernières finales qu'il avait
disputées et on ne donnait pas cher de
lui face à boris becker qui l'a pourtant
pinet gens ma mère ce soupir de
soulagement stefan edberg va bien failli
ne jamais le pousser lui le maudit des
finales perturbé dans sa victoire au
point d'en oublier presque de serrer la
main de celui dont il venait de
s'exorciser boris becker becker sa bête
noire depuis wimbledon 1988 et dont le
service canon lui donner des cauchemars
cette fois ed baird n'a pas craqué il a
fait simple service volée et rage de
vaincre
becker perturbé alors visité
consciencieusement le court ed baird
calme maître du jeu capable d'accélérer
juste quand il le fallait pas
son arme favorite hier soir le revers
tout en finesse en touche et en place et
un jeu ralentit que n'apprécie pas
becker cela suffit pour être pris à
contre temps surtout lorsque l'on est
aussi précis et berg a retrouvé le
sourire lui aussi l'ambition et espérons
le car aujourd'hui il est le maître
bravo hébert georges bortoli vous le
disais tout à l'heure la des événements
importants la journée était bien en
marque de la réunion de l'otan à
bruxelles
la rencontre des membres du pacte de
varsovie à moscou une rencontre
historique puisque je vous rappelle les
participants ont condamné
rétroactivement leur propre intervention
en tchécoslovaquie 21 ans
l'ambiance était pour le moins présente
dans la grande salle du kremlin entre
les différentes délégations
mais il ya plusieurs manières de
raconter l'histoire c'est ce que va nous
prouver avec un peu d'irrévérence mais
beaucoup de sympathie pour mikhaïl
gorbatchev
notre ami las en guerre
l'ambiance est plutôt tendue au début de
cette réunion personne n'ayant
visiblement envie de rigoler ni les
hongrois ni les bulgares ni les tchèques
alors le boute en train de service
monsieur gorbatchev franc personne tente
quelque chose le bide
pas même un reer folie monsieur tian
c'est ce que se demande même s'il ne
rêve pas l'ambiance que ce dégel
toujours pas alors monsieur gorbatchev
va raconter ses rencontres avec le pape
et monsieur bush ou le climat a été
franchement détendue
j'ai bon monsieur gorbatchev jette
l'épongé
un quine à paris non plus c'est jacques
osinski puisqu'il n'avait pas son
oreillette le seul à avoir compris la
plaisanterie à en faire trembler
légèrement sa caméra le cameramen sans
doute l'oeil de moscou ont re devenu
sérieux pour les pronostics de pierrette
bref pour le quarté et le quinté plus
demain à vincennes les voici le neuf le
2 le 14 le 17 le vin le 16 le 11 et le
15 voilà j'ai tout juste encore le temps
de vous dire que l'invité de françois
ponchelet demain matin à 7 heures 45
pour les 4 vérités sera le sénateur plus
elle le grand spécialiste de
l'audiovisuel dans un instant josé
beurre lapierre va nous parler du temps
dès demain et tout à l'heure henri
sannier vous présentera la dernière
édition du journal très bonne soirée sur
antenne 2 à demain 20 heures